hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where right now i am loading
in to play
sifu i have been very very very excited
to try this game out combat looks
somewhat like awkward like sleeping dogs
um
but i would say more fast paced from
what we've seen and i'm interested to
see if it ends up being like super but
mashy or if that is the case in it
it is more of a rhythmic kind of thing
so this is a preview build um an
enormous thank you to kepler
uh interactive
for giving me access to this build um
this build is from october so i imagine
the team is still working on a bunch of
stuff
and uh obviously playing in december
right now game comes out in february and
they said that this is the first half of
the second chapter i believe i don't
know how long we're going to be able to
play for um but yes so we're probably
missing
some tutorial stuff here
this is going to be law i would guess
great seafood known for her wugwan which
was open to student of all social pluses
she runs a gigantic company created from
scratch a few years ago this firm is
heavily involved in philanthropy and
investments
i met sean several times when i was a
kid he was a kung fu student our fathers
knew each other's as sifus he was
alongside yang when they destroyed his
father's school and mine once a month he
goes to this burning
party in the club so i guess this is
going to be like
a board of people we're trying to take
down or something notes to myself down
here objects in the environment can be
really useful if i find myself
surrounded some hits are quite hard to
parry i should try to avoid them okay so
we should be dodging as well as parrying
if i broke down their defense i can
easily take them down give me a bit of
energy
i've noticed some locked passage i might
keep in mind that those passage can be
shortcut or new location to explore i
should look around for those dragon
shrines interesting
i can vault over tables desk fence
obstacles okay
this pendant apparently helped me to
resurrect but at the cost of aging me
more and more the number of coins left
depends on my age and allow me to use an
unlock so that's right so this game has
a
dying mechanic where as you die you
actually get older um
i should try to stay as young as
possible each time i die i can unlock
new techniques according to the number
of coins left on my pennant so i wonder
if
as you get older you can get new
abilities
by using focus i can aim specific weak
points on an opponent hitting a point it
will increase my focus gauge
cool good to know
can i take that i would like that
oh well that's punch
x that seems like a light attack
why it's going to be heavy attack i'm
going to parry is b a b and a don't seem
to do anything right
now okay rt is run
and dodge
okay rb is going to be powery i reckon
excited to check out the timing
this is a skill tree
i do not have any xp okay
face mash focus that weapon only blade
weapon only okay this is let's just
let's just find out
i'm guessing this is gonna be where we
let's do it
i'm very excited
so far very into the music
very into the art style
um looking forward to seeing how the
combat plays out
i don't know how much of a story this
game actually has
um
the club that's why that bite is gonna
be the guy you knew was a
kid look forward to it
forget about it
if you're not on the list you're not
getting inside
what list
keanu reeves
look at
him
open
private party back off now
oh it's fighting time okay
oh i want to see how parry works
it's good it feels awesome it's like a
very quick sort of like you just really
tap it fast
okay
all right
i'm loving this style
yeah
what do you want uh
none of your business i'm sorry
guys
we got a problem here i did not mean to
try and fight you okay hello yeah
oh he's got a bat
i would like the bat i would like the
bat oh oh god i got hit by a bat oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh my god
that happened so fast
oh what did i just do
oh my god he'd be the crap out of me
with that bat
i'm not ready for this
or maybe i am oh take a bat
that sounds good okay
please don't hit me
very nice okay where is shawn
he
he's with the fighters for for the
burning that doesn't help
only sean's disciples have passes to get
inside
we'll see about that you actually didn't
explain it any better i don't know what
where he is
creamy
it's all right
this this place is going off look how
hard this hits
truly truly a party
[Music]
all right everybody
all right
oh no
i thought she was still out
[Music]
[Music]
select point
[Music]
oh did i lose my back
[Music]
is very cool
it's super like oh hello
super fast
okay what's up with you
[Music]
oh oh oh my okay
okay i've died so what happens oh i can
unlock stuff though oh
maybe that's why it is that way so when
you die
you come back to the screen where you
get xp so you can unlock stuff i don't
have a staff
oh an item weapon props directly from
the ground that sounds cool
weapon catch
strength to an enemy's knee knocking
them down
round counter
i'm gonna go with this one
that one
how do i unlock it
did i unlock it i'm not sure
21 not so bad
[Music]
this music is awesome
[Music]
this is really fast like genuinely like
so
damn that feels good though it's very
very cool
i need the access card
[Music]
structure reserve increase your maximum
structure health on takedown that seems
good
weapon durability
i'm gonna go with that one
let's go i'm excited
this is so cool
[Music]
give me that health back boy oh oh you
came out
oh what why is he flaming now
what the hell
uh i'm scared sir
i wanna use my focus on you leave me
alone
i can't do anything always down i wanna
grab something else to throw
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't want to die i don't want to die
i don't want to die
i don't understand why he's on fire i'm
very scared
[Music]
damn it
no did i not
weapon catch
that's permanently unlocked okay so i
already had that
parry at the right moment uh
thigh cut focus
swing
i'm gonna do that one
let's rise again
22. it's all right it's happening slowly
i'm scared of him though he's making me
panic hard
[Music]
keep rolling
why did i accidentally make him go i
don't i don't know what happened
oh my gosh
wow i'm so sorry i really ruined it oh
god
jump scare it's getting better of you oh
no no no no no no bad spot bad spot
that's what okay okay i feel like the
camera kind of gunned me down
just jumped two years really you want
some more i showed it
[Music]
i tried to
block that
not easy
get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice
i just
ended her oh my god okay
i thought you were dead
and you were not
want to throw them at this guy
it's too far away that's a shame that
would have been fun
give me the bath
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh
very very very very satisfying to play
that's a cool intro
i probably didn't need to kill whoever
that is
ruin everybody's day let's go
[Music]
this is super fun i i hope that you can
see how how it
is gameplay like expresses that
clearly hotel but it is very very fun
the rhythm is really really precise
[Music]
a burning event excellent
i don't have to kill her then
all right
these boys oh i'm scared
i would like to throw things out there
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh my god no no no no
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i was worried about that okay get out of
that get out of that get out of there
i didn't i'm sorry i didn't mean to i
i'm really sorry about that
damn damn it damn it that's a good throw
they have
i wonder if i should just be more
aggressive i think that maybe would work
better by just like
you got to stop trying to
be afraid and just deal with the parries
oh my god i'm so sorry ma'am please get
out of the way
[Music]
i don't i'm just assuming that that's
the stuff that it was telling me that i
can't parry but i'll be interested to
see
how the people play through this i feel
like i'm at such a risk of dying that
i'm not willing to take risks
maybe if i watch other people play or
find out maybe those are variable i'm
assuming that they're not and then i
have to dodge them but
hey
we learn it we learn
[Music]
this is like genuinely exciting
um all right my hands are sweaty though
that's closed for tonight
i disagree
hey didn't you hear what you said
damn it woman
i could feel my own game of face damn it
she swept me okay i didn't see it that's
a shame um okay
that's already unlocked what's this one
sounds cool to me
let's go
how old am i now
that's basically ancient haven't you had
enough
but maybe
that's what i'm assuming he said to
dodge maybe i'm wrong
a gentleman
kick his ass
take his [ __ ] head off
otter
animated oh my god
all right
oh hello there's a big boy
[Music]
oh the throw
ah damn
damn damn damn
i do feel like i'm having
some fights with the camera some of the
time
now i got back problems
oh my god i didn't even see him
okay
[Music]
i like the lighting
neat okay
[Music]
well hello there sir
[Music]
you are not supposed to be a part of
tonight's guy i feel like everybody kind
of sounds like keanu reeves
uh let me let me through i don't want
any trouble
nice
[Music]
throw some [ __ ]
it's like i feel like my stamina is in a
bad spot right now
it's so funny
all right
[Music]
damn i thought i dodged it i'm gonna die
again all right drunk he's caught he's
tough
this is gonna be really fun to figure
out though is what i'm gonna say is like
i feel like this game like
as you play through it you get better
is going to get um
yeah more oh my head changed that's cool
there were combos in here why don't we
try some sweep palm strike
push kick roundhouse kick huh
backbreaker yyxy
oh i did do it i think god
[Music]
did that wrong
he's not the right person to try this on
maybe the next guy
[Music]
he's kicking my butt
oh god okay
he's not throwing anything at me
i guess why not
cool when it happens
all right
[Music]
oh so i think i did just carry his kick
maybe you
[Music]
oh you can okay that's oh my my stamina
you can i i just now learned that you
actually can carry that stuff
you just have to be oh i didn't know i
would have died then
um you just have to be really
good
good to know i didn't know that you
could i thought you had to dodge them
[Music]
finally
i'd like to try that again now though
disciples
a pause i took from one of sean's
disciples i guess oh he's not even sean
how excited
above this door are the three trials
the trials
agility dexterity
okay
that is awesome that is so much fun i
love the style i love the sound um
i i feel like i just scratched the
surface and i'm absolutely gonna play
this again has retry button um to get
that timing down better because i felt
like i was i was very much just learning
obviously using my first impressions so
i am allowed to stream the game a little
bit more this month so maybe i'll do
that and see like how few deaths i can
get and see how i get under the rhythm
as i'm playing through it um
it's really satisfying very very tense i
like the pacing a lot
that was awesome that was absolutely
awesome yeah let me know what you guys
think if you like c streams let me know
i can do that i can probably replay this
preview as many times as i like open
different doors see if maybe the that
card will let me go back
to different areas
that ruled wow